رغم المسائل الرميه الى وقف اطلاق النار
في السودان الى ان المشهد لم يتغير من
خلال استمرار القتال بين طرفي الصرع اتفاق
وقف اطلاق النار الاخير اجهض تماما كما
حدث مع اتفاقيات الهدنه التي سبقتها
الطرفان لم يصل لاي ارضيه للتفاهم من اجل
ايجاد حل سلمي للازمه التي اندلعت قبل
ازيد من شهر فلماذا يا ترى لم تنجح جهود
الوساطه في اقناع الطرفين باحترام
اتفاقيات وقف اطلاق النار للاجابه على هذا
السؤال يجب الانتباه الى ان الاتفاق وقف
اطلاق النار الاخير كان الهدف منه انساني
فقط وهذا يعكس الرفض التام لكلا الطرفين
في فتح مفاوضات للتوصل الى اتفاق سياسي
كما ان الطرفين معا لم يبديا اي ليونه في
المفاوضات في ظل تشبث كل واحد منهما
بموقفه واتهام الطرف الاخر بالتسبب في
الازمه يضاف الى ذلك عجز الاحزاب المدنيه
في التدخل للوساطه في ظل ضعف علاقتها
بالطرفين
الخطر الاكبر المحدق بالبلاد الان هو ان
تزلق السودان الى حرب الى مسارات اكثر
فداحا كما ان غياب الاستقرار داخل البلاد
قد يدفع المدنيين الى التسلح للدفاع عن
انفسهم ما قد يتسبب في انتشار الاسلحه في
البلاد هذا ويبقى سيناريو اندلاعي حرب
اهليه هو التهديد الاخطر على الاطلاق
والتي قد تندلع في حال استهداف جماعات
عرقيه بعينها
ومهما كان المسار الذي ستاخذه المعارك فان
المدنيين هم الضحيه الاكبر بهذا الخصوص
قالت منظمه الامم المتحده ان المدنيين
يعانون من المعارك المتواصله واصفه للوضع
الانساني بالماساوي اوضح الذات المنظمه ان
الاشتباكات اسفرت عن مقتل 850 مدنيا فضلا
عن اصابه 3500 شخص ونزوح مئات الالاف
وقالت المنظمه الامميه دائما ان الاطراف
المتقاتله تنتهك جميع حقوق الانسان مشيره
الى ان المدنيين باتوا يعانون من نقص
الادويه كما اكدت تعرضا العديد من المنازل
للنهب مشيره في الوقت نفسه الى وجود نقص
في المياه والطعام
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات